und wieder mal haben sie zugeschlagen
die gaffer teatro diesmal die a1 bei
neuenkirchen firmen im landkreis
osnabrück im dichten urlaubsverkehr
krachte dort ein frisch verheiratetes
ehepaar auf ein stauende insgesamt acht
menschen wurden dabei verletzt
rettungskräfte wollten eine neue brücke
nutzen um an die unfallstelle zu
gelangen
dort erlebten sie eine böse
überraschungen gaffer blockierten die
brücke um fotos und videos zu machen die
kollegen autobahnpolizei berichten dass
es beim thema rettungsgasse
offensichtlich schon umdenken beim
bürger stattgefunden hat und sich da
eine verbesserung eingestellt hat das
problem rund ums thema gefahren
schaulust offensichtlich in den köpfen
der leute und nicht angekommen und jeder
sollte sich mal wirklich gedanken
darüber machen was das für einen sinn
überhaupt hat wenn er fotos und videos
macht und diese vielleicht sogar noch im
internet in sozialen medien verbreitet
die bergung der verletzten wurden
dadurch erheblich erschwert polizisten
mussten die brücke erst träumen ehe die
verletzten in krankenhäuser gebracht
werden konnten die vier unfallfahrzeuge
wurden durch abschleppdienste geborgen
auf der a1 kam es und zwei stunden lang
zu massiven behinderungen